foreign
I'm glad to present our work what can
crypto do for decentralized mechanism
Design This is a joint work with Elaine
Sheen how Trump from kanigan Miller
University
so in this work we focus on transaction
FEMA councils what is a transaction fee
mechanism as we know real estate on
blockchain is real expansive so users
want to have their transactions
confirmed and often users would have to
compete with each other to get their
transactions confirmed we can view this
as an auction where the miner is selling
the slots in a block to the users
in this case we need to run a so-called
transaction fee mechanism to decide
which transactions to confirm how much
they pay and how much the miner gets
for example Bitcoin employs a simple
first-price production
let's just assume that the block size is
one
the highest bid will be confirmed and it
pays its own bid all the payment go to
the miner
as we have learned from classical
algorithmic Game Theory a first prize
auction is not good because it
incentivizes users to read untruthfully
for example it may be my best strategy
to be barely enough to be the top bit
so I will get confirmed and pay the
least possible price
what's interesting here is that all
classical mechanisms we know fail
for example we know that second price
options are a golden standard In
classical mechanism design because they
incentivize the builders to be
truthfully
so why not just Implement second price
auction what can go around here
for example in second press auction the
highest big 9 will be confirmed and it
pays the second highest bit 6 as the
price to the minor
however on blockchain a strategic Miner
can inject a fake transaction with B
let's say eight
now the confirm bit 9 has to pay 8 to
the minor rather than six
so minor can increase its gain by
deviating
more generally in classical setting we
typically assume that the minor or the
auctioneer is fully trusted and we care
about designing mechanisms that
incentivizes the users to be truthfully
in decentralized environment however the
miner may also have incentive to cheat
and it may not implement the mechanism
Faithfully
that's why the classical mechanisms are
not a good fit here
so we want to ask this question what
makes a dream transaction fee mechanism
what properties are the incentive
aspects of transaction theme mechanism
we want to have to design an ideal
transaction in female cancer
thank you
recently a line of work has looked into
this space and most of these work agree
that the following three properties are
important
the first one is called user incentive
compatibility abbreviated as UIC
the it guarantees that a user does not
want to deviate so a user will bid
truthfully and this is the same notion
as in classical mechanism design
in addition to this we want to make sure
that the minor
we want to make sure that we have minor
incentive compatibility or equivalently
we want to guarantee that the miner does
not have an incentive to deviate so the
miner want to implement the mechanism
honestly
last but not the least in the blockchain
environment it is easy for players to
form binding smart contracts in
particular they can rely on Smart
contracts as an enforcement mechanism to
split up their joint games
therefore we also want a third property
called site contract proofness or SCP
for short
in particular suppose that a minor forms
a collision with C users
and the Coalition is aiming to maximize
their joint gain
in this case the coalition's best
response is to follow the protocol
honestly
among these three properties the last
two arises in this new decentralized
environment and these are the new
challenges we are facing that makes
transaction fee mechanism depart from
classical mechanism design
and team rough guard is ec21 work he
asked the question can we have a dream
transaction fee mechanism
so the closest we have come to in terms
of a dream transaction fee mechanism is
actually ethereum's EIP 1559
let me quickly mention how it works it
gracefully switch between two modes of
operation
when the network is congested namely
when there are a lot of transactions
waiting to be confirmed it approximates
the behavior of a first press auction
which is not good as we mentioned
with a network is uncongested however
their mechanism approximates a simple
post a price option in other words there
is a take it or leave it offer called
the posting price
If you bid higher than posted price you
get confirmed and you pay the posted
price
if you beat lower than the posted price
would you would not be confirmed
and here all payments are burned rather
than paid to the miner
so team rough guards improved that EIP
1559 satisfies all three properties we
want if we are willing to assume
infinite block size or equivalently when
there is no congestion so posted price
auction is good when we have infinite
block size
in reality of course the block size is
finite and congestion will happen every
now and then in this case we still don't
know any good transaction female cancer
let's consider a naive idea let's
suppose the block size is one so we
randomly pick a bit that is at least the
posted price to confirm
it pays the posted price and all
payments are burnt
so is this a good transaction fee
mechanism it actually satisfies UIC and
mic
however it is not one SCP so basically a
collision of a minor and a user can
increase their joint gain by db18
to see how they perform the attack let's
imagine the following case the block
size is one in the post hit price S5
so all the bids in the mempool is 10.
so now instead of randomly choosing a
bit to confirm the miner will just
confirm excluding user friend's bit
so this increased the probability of the
cloning user being confirmed from
two-fifth from one-fifth to one
and this increases the expected join
gain of the coalition
actually this example captures the main
idea of the impossibility result in
Chong and she saw that 23 work they
showed that under finite block size no
non-trivial transaction fee mechanism
satisfies all three properties
by trivial we mean that no transaction
is ever confirmed in the block
so this is quite pessimistic
so in this work we asked the question
can we use crypto to help circumvent
this impossibility can we use crypto to
force the miner to implement the
mechanism Faithfully
and we give a positive answer
in this work we propose a new model
called NPC assistant model where MPC
stands for multi-party computation a
power of our cryptographic primitive
in the MPC assisted model instead of
having a single minor in claiming the
mechanism we let a group of miners
together to implement the mechanism
to do this we let each user send their
bid to other miners
then all the miners interact among
themselves to run the Primitive card
multi-part computation based on all the
bids they received
the multi-party computation computes the
output of the mechanism and it
guarantees the correctness of the output
as long as a majority number of miners
are honest
that means the transaction fee mechanism
will be honestly implemented
note that an honest execution the users
do not need to talk to each other they
only talk to the miners
so basically we can view this whole box
as an ideal functionality it receives
users bit as input and gives us the
output of the transaction fee mechanism
so this model enforces the correct
implementation of the transaction FEMA
accounts
in this work we basically show The
Following results
first we show that cryptography in-depth
helps to circumvent the impossibility
result in and she saw that 23 work
however we also show that cryptography
does not trivialize transaction feeding
cancer
although it guarantees although it
enforces correctly in the implementation
of the transaction fee mechanism and
thus brace the design space closer to
that of classical mechanism design but
still it differs a lot from classical
mechanism design because first here we
still care about Minor user coalition
and second we allow each users and the
miner may still inject fake transactions
and users can choose to drop out
these are usually not considered in
classical mechanism designs
more specifically in our paper we give
the following results we call the model
without NPC as the plane model
so previous work ruled out the
possibility of a dream transaction
female cancer in the play model whereas
we show that in the MPC assistant model
we can design a dream transaction
between mechanism
however the mechanism is only one SCP it
is not incentive compatible against
minor including with more users
and we actually show that this is
inherent
we prove that it is impossible to have a
dream transaction feed mechanism if the
minor clued with more two or more users
even in the MPC assistant model
therefore we also consider another
dimension of relaxation
what if we allow the coalition to gain a
little bit but no more than Epsilon more
utility
in this case under this relaxation we
showed that the social welfare the sum
of the utility of all users and all
miners is unscalable in the plane model
and by scalable we mean that if everyone
increased their double their bits then
the social welfare should double
so basically we want the social welfare
to grow linearly as the bid grows
however in the MPC assistant model we
give a mechanism that achieves optimal
social welfare
so from this table we can see that
indeed crypto helps a lot it makes what
was originally impossible in the play
model now possible
so in the rest of the talk I will focus
on the feasibility we achieved in the
MPC assistant model
we will first see how to build a dream
transaction film mechanism in the MPC
assistant model
and we will see why it can it is not too
SCP so why it is not incentive
compatible when the minor fluid with two
users
then we'll show if we relax the notion
to approximate incentive compatibility
we will be able to construct a dream
transaction fee mechanism satisfying all
properties as well as achieving optimal
social welfare
so now let's first look at our
feasibility that is one SCP in the MPC
assistant model satisfies all properties
so a single observation is that now with
the MPC assistant model we are
guaranteed that the transaction in
mechanism is implemented correctly
so the rent hosted price option with
random selection we mentioned now
becomes a good transaction fee mechanism
that is that satisfies all properties
where we randomly choose one bit from
the bit that is at least a posted price
to confirm it pays the posted price and
all payments burnt
now since by the MPC assistant model we
are guaranteed that the MPC guarantees
that it will randomly choose a bit to
confirm so the miner cannot help its
including user friend anymore
so now it is one SCP in the MPCs System
model and we have a dream transaction of
being accounts
however this is not to SCP that means
even if the minor clue with only two
users they have a strategy to increase
their joint gain
to see why this is the case
let's assume still that the block size
is one and post a price is 5. and these
two users in the orange are the two
users in the Coalition the big one the
big user has been 10 and the small user
has been five
so note that here no matter so for this
small user since its true value is five
its utility is always zero
so for the Collision to increase their
joint utility they basically want to
increase the utility of the big user
to do this the small user will choose to
drop out
to increase the probability of the big
user being confirmed
so for example before I drop out the
probability of the big user being
confirmed is one-fifth
and now it's one quarter
so this captures the idea of our
impossibility proof we can actually show
that even in the MPC assistant model it
is impossible to achieve two SCP UIC and
mic simultaneously
so to circumvent this impossible result
we consider another dimension of
relaxation what if we allow the minor
user coalition to gain a little bit more
does that gives us any feasibility
and the answer is positive
so in the if we consider approximate
incentive compatibility we can construct
this MPC assistant diluted posted price
options it is UIC mic and approximate to
SCP
as a heads up here I'm only given the uh
example for c for clue for two including
users but this can generalize us to
arbitrary C
and the intuition behind is basically
that sure
um a small user can choose to drop out
to help it speak uh to help its friend
um but when the population is large the
increment is very small so the hell so
you cannot help too much
specifically in MPC assisted diluted
positive price what we do is as follows
so first we choose our beds at least the
poster price as candidates
if the number of candidates is too small
say less than a predetermined threshold
T then we pad with enough dummy bits or
say we dilute
the candidates pool
then we randomly choose kbids from the
padded pool where this K is the block
size
and finally each confirmed bid pays R of
course those padded dummy bids will be
ignored
and all payments are burned
before we see why this is to SCP I want
to mention that when there are a lot of
large bids let's say when there are a
lot of Biz larger than M and we select
the posted price as half up m in this
case we achieve optimal social welfare
so now let's see why this is approximate
to SCP
note that if the number of candidates is
small
say for example in this case the posted
press S5 and we only have these three
candidates
then we will Pat Dom Abyss to make it a
lot to make it t-bits so 10 bits and we
randomly choose one bit to confirm out
of 10 bits
so for the big user the probability that
it is confirmed is just one tenth
even if the small user drop out the
probability of it being confirmed it's
still 110. so in this case
dropping out does not help
however if the number of candidates is
very large say in this case all the bids
are candidates so we have far more than
10 bids as candidates
in this case for the small user to if
the small user dropping drops out then
it ended helps but it cannot help too
much because the probability of the big
user being confirmed can be at most
one-tenth since the number of candidates
is definitely larger than the
predetermined threshold
so in this case even if it drops out it
cannot help too much
so this is the core idea of this diluted
poster price option
so in our paper we also give the
following more results
in our paper we also give a
characterization of infinite block size
in the MPC assistant model
and also we showed how we can achieve
positive minor Revenue although in the
talk we only focus on the case where all
payments are burnt
and furthermore we also give other ideas
of overcoming The Impossible result
which is approximating incentive
compatibility
there are a lot of interesting open
questions left by this work
so first in this work we only consider
one shot auction but we know in reality
the auction is running repeatedly so it
is interesting to consider the repeated
nature in well-scale strategies
second in this work we are focusing on
the theoretical feasibility of
transaction feed mechanism so we did not
try to improve the efficiency or
practicality
and it would be nice to figure out a way
to make the MPCs System model practical
and finally uh there are other
interesting problems related to
transaction female cancer for example in
reality The Ordering of the transactions
in your blog actually matters and of
course let's say in ethereum each
transaction may have different size we
did not address these problems in this
work but it will be interesting to
address these in the future
thank you so much